[Musique]
et c'est inviter ses voûtes etienne à au
regard kova vous êtes journaliste vous
êtes ukrainienne responsable du
département international à l'ukraine
crisis media center bonjour à vous merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur france 24 depuis le début
de l'année 24 journalistes et un
collaborateur ont été tués dans le monde
7 en ukraine selon reporters sans
frontières concrètement informer c'est
risqué sa vie en ukraine
oui tout à fait et on a même reçu un
chiffre plus élevé aujourd'hui selon
l'union de journalistes nationale la
licra vingt trois personnes ont perdu
leurs vies déjà depuis le 24 février en
ukraine y compris bien sûr les
journalistes internationaux aussi
présent sur les lieux les premières
victimes je rappellerai c'était un
touriste américain qui était à irving
dans cette ville au nord de kiev qui a
été tuée et donc son collègue a été l'un
blessé lors de moments où il essayait de
couvrir justement les combats très
intenses au mois de mars à côté d'eux
qu'ils vivent donc 23 personnes c'est
beaucoup souvent ce sont des des gens
qui essaient de documenter ce qui se
passe sur le terrain mais parfois ce
sont aussi des cas compte tout à fait
récemment de lors de cette attaque et
sur cuivre attaques par missiles une
journaliste de radio svoboda et
journalistes ukrainiens qui s'appelle
vire a dû me claude periou sa vie dans
son appartement
voilà au moment de tout à fait quotidien
donc c'est un hasard qui fait aussi
l'eau la mort des civils et après il ya
aussi les histoires de de kidnapping de
celle à venir de nos activités comme ma
collègue qui s'appelle victoria rochina
qui a été arrêté ambiance c'est un mois
de mars il faisait un reportage sur les
rescapés de marioupol à bergues à ce que
nos gouvernants c'était à ce moment là
et commence à être réoccupée déjà par
par l'armée russe il a été kidnappé pour
plusieurs jours heureusement elle a pu
être libérée mais finalement
et elle a même refusé de parler à la
presse à la presse internationale y
compris suite à un traumatisme
on sait même pas ce qu'est ce que l'été
est arrivé mais on peut imaginer des
atrocités malheureusement
malheureusement commune durant cette
guerre tetiana au regard kova de façon
plus personnelle comment la guerre
at-elle profondément bouleversé votre
manière à vous de pratiquer votre métier
oui tout à fait c'était un moment
décisif justement le début de la guerre
parce que le crâne était attaqué par tôt
et donc la question que se posaient pour
les journalistes parce qu'on n'est pas
tous les journalistes de guerre on n'est
pas tous
on n'a pas tous l'habitude de se rendre
dans les zones de combat plusieurs
journalistes et je parle notamment pour
nos deux femmes journalistes qui est
surtout les femmes qui avaient des
enfants donc la question primordiale
était la question de sécurité pour les
enfants aussi dont plusieurs dans mois
après une semaine passée 1 qui vivent à
côté de cuivre on a pris la route vers
l'ouest dans les endroits plus sécurisé
et on a essayé de continuer à travailler
à distance bien sûr ce n'était plus un
travail de reporter sur ce qui se
passait sur place mais d'expliquer de
raconter ce qui se passe notamment pour
la communauté internationale dans les
langues concots maîtrise mais c'est vrai
que la guerre elle voulait beaucoup
fragilisée justement tout le tout lui
tient en fait puisque plusieurs journaux
plusieurs sites d'internet puisque y
avait plus de publicité il y avait plus
de budget en fait pour plusieurs donc il
y avait aussi cette campagne de de
caochangdi n'en fait pour trouver de
l'argent pour payer les salaires donc
c'est tout un secteur qui est fragilisée
pour pour des questions de sécurité mais
aussi par les questions financier en
fait comment est-ce qu'un média peu
qu'on tient à vivre comme qui a pas de
budget quand tout s'écroule et tout
s'effondre donc c'est un moment
extraordinaire il pour toute amitié vous
êtes de retour à kiev depuis deux
semaines un jeu croix comment vous
comptez justement exercer votre métier
ces prochains jours ces prochaines
semaines on continue on retient travail
on n'a pas arrêté on a fait certaines
choses à distance la mettant c'est vrai
que je suis de retour
on continue comme avant la guerre en
fait parce que qui ivre et la région de
qui le revend libéré donc il ya presque
plus de presque plus de signe direct de
la vierge bien sûr il ya des alertes
aérien bien sûr il ya des missiles qui
arrivent mais à part cela on fonctionne
avec un mass media center comme avant je
visitais butcher ir ping airs ping gosto
mêle aussi vendredi dernier justement
pour voir des mecs propose you bien sûr
c'était un mois après les atrocités qui
ont les meurtres les viols qui ont eu
chaud là bas mais c'était important pour
moi en tant que journaliste mais aussi
en tant que craignant de savoir devoir
de mes propositions à quoi ressemble
voilà de l'occupation russe et à quoi
ressemble la ville qui a un vécu pendant
un mois sous cette occupation c'est
important puisque cette tâche de
témoigner de voir et témoigner de
raconter ses histoires que ce soit pour
le public ici à l'intérieur depuis à
l'étranger et aussi le communiquer à nos
enfants c'est aussi important
justement dans une telle guerre les
journalistes deviennent aussi des
témoins indésirables d'éventuels crimes
de guerre russes comment l'ol j'ai pour
laquelle vous travaillez à telle
rassembler des données sur ces massacres
présumés vous parliez de butch à dire
pin les massacres présumés qui se sont
produits dans ces villes proches de kiev
lors de ces massacres à nos collègues
sont pour la plupart se déplacer à
l'ouest donc c'est une équipe qui
travaille à distance donc on fait des
eaux ont recueilli des témoignages des
gens présents sur place présent sur
place qui nous livre des preuves qu'ils
ne prennent livre des photos mais non on
a collecté à tout en restant à distance
bien sûr que ça va changer dans les
semaines à venir on est plus présent on
est beaucoup plus présent aujourd'hui
parce que qui veut libérer on va
continuer de procéder de la sorte mais
c'est vrai que les les gens qui ceux qui
ont osé se rendre sur place sont
malheureusement plus prudents ont perdu
la leur vie je vais parler de ce cas de
max livin qu'on connaissait bien et est
notre collègue qui travaillait pour la
chaîne rollmatic et même pas pour
plusieurs arrêtés pour plusieurs la
chaîne internationale ou si c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours couvert la
guerre qui a survécu à un îlot vice qu
en 2014 2015 et le voile ce classeur
clement de troupe ukrainienne par
l'armée russe encore là bas plus de
trois cents 300 militaires ukrainiens
ont perdu leur vie il a fondé ce projet
heart is known as qu après ils risquent
donc d'être quelqu'un d'un courage
extraordinaire il faut il sort un dieu
en or de kif
13 13 14 15 mars en fait et on a
retrouvé son corps le 1er avril
justement après la libération de cette
région il a été tué par balle un fake
par un arme de chasse donc ce n'était
pas un obus qui l'a tué donc été tués
délibérément par justement l'armée russe
justement parce qu'elle voulait
témoigner mars était quelqu'un qui
voulait faire une photo qui pourrait
arrêter la bière c'était ça un peu ce
sont seulement en fait sa moto de vie et
donc il a laissé derrière lui quatre
enfants en bas âge en fait donc et voilà
donc après on voit le prix en fait que
les journalistes ils payent pour la
possibilité pour le mettre sur place et
pour le courage d'être sur place au
moment de la guerre c'est justement
toute la particularité indult du terrain
ils craignent ainsi le fait que les
journalistes sont désormais devenus des
cibles alors même que je le rappelle le
droit international elles exigent des
forces armées qu'elle les protège je
rappelle juste ces chiffres au moins
quatre tours de télévision ukrainienne
bombardée depuis le début de la guerre
plus de 32 chaînes de télévisions et
plusieurs dizaines de radios ont cessé
leur diffusion suite à des frappes c'est
donc l'information qui est directement
visé
oui tout à fait
cette attaque et je me rappelle très
bien la pac sur la chaîne de télévision
à
kyiv c'était d'un durant la première
semaine de la guerre sahara
des morts parmi des journalistes mais
heureusement les tentatives d que de
détruire le sait la circulation livre de
l'information n'ont pas n'ont pas réussi
puisque jusqu'aujourd'hui on peut
s'informer il ya plusieurs journaux
notamment l'internet qui fonctionne il
ya les chaînes de télévision qui sont là
il ya le marathon national en fait
l'information qui est en place depuis
les premières heures des invasions
russie continue jusqu'aujourd'hui nos
collègues nos enfants donc il ya plus de
chaînes de télé en fait il ya qu une
seule qu'une seule chance de te vient
quelques sorties à ce marathon et
marathon national et plusieurs
animateurs animatrices et journalistes
ils travaillent pour le souhaitent
pendant sur le pouvoir unique en fait
qui ne fait en fait que couvrir la
guerre 24 heures sur 24 depuis le
premier jour et ce sera comme ça je suis
convaincu jusqu'à le jour de la victoire
tetiana au regard kova journaliste
ukrainienne responsable du département
international à l'ukraine a crisis media
center merci beaucoup à vous pour votre
témoignage et ses éléments de
compréhension sur le terrain ukrainien
quand on est journaliste merci beaucoup
à vous